well the pandemic has impacted so many
businesses in different ways yeah it's a
change the way we communicate how we
work and as it turns out for a lot of
people how they actually feel about
themselves heather mills explains the
unique business boom behind those daily
virtual calls
zoom is having its moment and a lot of
women they're having an aha moment from
bad lighting and poor cameras staring at
yourself on conference calls all day
it's leading to a rush in cosmetic
beauty enhancements
call it a pandemic surge when much of
the world was focused on retaining
business flawless med spa expanded and
tripled its size we brought on another
injector just because the demand was so
much we couldn't keep up with it
botox fillers light therapy just a
little help from owner melanie speed
what cosmetic injections should do for
you is boost your self-confidence and
make you feel better you should do it
for yourself speed is a certified nurse
practitioner and certified aesthetic
nurse specialist she says her business
is booming many first-timers looking for
that beauty boost we've kind of
experienced what i like to call the zoom
boom people are at home they're working
from home they're on face time or zoom
more than ever they're seeing things
about their face and angles on their
face that they've never seen before so i
think it made people a lot more
self-conscious lena weil says taking her
business virtual did exactly that when
you get the zoom
like you see every little
wrinkle so she opted for a little botox
then lip filler it's more like looking
better and feeling better about yourself
a refreshed more youthful self what
happens as we age is we lose the volume
in this area of the mid face the area
between eyes and mouth so we lose the
fat pads and it creates what looks like
the melting snowman that's where cheek
fillers come in i'm just going to wipe
off your numbing cream speed says it's
one of her top three requested
procedures behind lip filler and bowtop
i'm just going to mark your anatomy
where your cheekbones are a quick
in-office visit and little down time it
usually doesn't bruise too bad so she
should be fine couple days week at the
most another benefit to working from
home they're at home they can just throw
on a mask they can put a filter on
beautiful no pain
no pain no wow i see the difference and
she can always add more this treatment
will last about a year but steve says
she encourages a natural look which is
why she's well known among the stars i
do a lot of celebrities that don't talk
about it for a while though she's happy
to tell friends about her enhancements
women we do so much
we pick up the kids we cook we work so
why not looking beautiful
the american academy of facial plastic
and reconstructive surgery is also
reporting a boom in surgical procedures
for the same reasons the ability to
recover at home and healing with masks
heather mills live local now